اذا المشاهدين نتابع معكم صور الركام يعني
التي تتكرر منذ ساعات الصباح
مره اخرى اذا في حلب التي انهارت فيها
العديد من المباني نستمع قليلا للصوت
الطبيعي مع استمرار جهود الانقاذ
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا الكرام كما تتابعون صور
لاستمرار عمليات الانقاذ في حلب في سوريا
حتى الان الحصيله
3700 قتيل جراء هذا الزلزال في كل من
تركيا وسوريا ولكن الصحه العالميه الان
ترسم صوره متشائمه بان هذه الحصيله قد
تتضاعف ثماني مرات اذا بالنظر الى الدمار
الكبير شاهدوا الان هذه الجرافات هذه
الجرافات تحاول ان يعني تبعد الركام قليلا
لعل وعسى يكون هناك انتشال
لناجين من تحت هذا الركام او يعني انتشال
الضحايا الذين فارقوا الحياه جراء انهيار
المبنى عليهم